there's a new documentary by the guy
wrote coke cocaine Cowboys did cocaine
Cowboys and a bunch other documentaries
Billy Korb yep
Billy cord Corbin
you got it I don't wanna choke on his
lame smarter anyway Billy has a new
document called screech screwball yeah
it's all about Alex Rodriguez and the
steroid scandal and one of the guys in
is a fake doctor who would wear
stethoscope around his neck like he got
his degree in Psych junkie overseas
University and wasn't legal to practice
medicine in the United States but who
call himself a doctor and he had like
the stethoscope that he'd wear it well
in his office he'd walk around with a
stethoscope around his neck like hanging
or as neck I just again he's gonna check
your heart meanwhile all he's doing is
prescribing steroids it was amazing that
was walking around he posed as a doctor
and had multiple patients I remember
this is in Florida the same place I
guess it afforded to it must be pretty
of course it's in Florida is this name
does this name say Malachi yeah that's a
creepy name that's like children of the
corn right that's like how do you
pronounce that mind
Malachi Malachi yeah that's that is
ballsy do you wait a minute that's not
his real name Merritt malachi
love-robinson that sounds like a
character from like some sort of porno
there is dr. Malachi a love match d hhp
- CA MP - TV dad all those things HIV
what are all those other things it is
health care proxy maybe some bullshit
EMP I don't know what the hell that
sounds like a gas station in Kansas
let's read his thing listen says is a
well doctor malachi love-robinson is a
well-rounded professional that treats
and cares for patients using a system of
practice that basis treatment on
physiological functions and abnormal
conditions on natural laws governing the
human body that doesn't even that's a
run-on not a sentence doctor
love-robinson utilizes physiological
psychological and the
annika methods such as air water light
earth photo therapy food and herb
therapy psychotherapy electrotherapy
physiotherapy Meccano therapy naturopath
Corrections and manipulation and natural
methods or modalities together with
natural medicines natural processed
foods and herbs and nature's remedies
what you just said the only thing that
was true about that was manipulation how
is this guy like who who read that and
went all right we're in yeah who read
that was like I need to make an
appointment immediately found the real
doctor all these other doctors that
don't use manipulation all of them now I
would not go to that doctor huh yet
offices so someone had to like rent him
the spot said they believed him too not
just the offices he at least had an off
a office like an off you gotta think a
guy who's that good of a bullshitter
that pretends to be a doctor actually
gets patients who's got a stethoscope
got a website is it that good but it's
good enough that he's got patients likes
it actually worked like imagine being so
crazy that you tell everybody you're a
doctor you don't know shit about medical
medical practices you know you read his
little bio there and you get offices
then you get patients you treating
patients